2020 qu'ovide crise sanitaire crise
économique et sociale 2021 coheed vaccin
espoirs relance marc fesneau ministre
des relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne
il a deux périmètres donc ça fait deux
phrases relations avec le parlement
c'est un travail de diplomatie
parlementaire diplomatie c'est quoi
c'est organisé lors du jour entre le
gouvernement et le parlement
c'est s'assurer d'un bon dialogue entre
la majorité et gouvernement c'est
s'assurer d'un dialogue aussi entre le
gouvernement et en opposition le respect
des oppositions puis la participation
citoyenne c'est plutôt de faire ce sujet
existe depuis on n'arrive pas sur un
terrain vierge et beaucoup d' expertise
au niveau local mais ici au niveau
national fo le il faut le dire
et donc c'est d'essayer de faire encore
plus émerger ce fait de la participation
citoyenne en mettant en évidence à la
fois les avantages
et puis les principes de méthodologie
qui font que ça réussit ou ça réussit
pas pour tous ceux qui ont regardé ces
images c'est la fragilité de démocratie
l'attention qu'on doit porter aux mots
qu'on a quand on les responsables
publics
quand on porte les mots de la violence
de la haine et de la division
eh bien ça se transforme en haine
violence division d'un point de vue
physique et donc sa porte l'exigence
pour les responsables publics de faire
du débat de nouer des débats mais en
même temps de le faire dans le respect
des institutions parce que dès lors
qu'on ne respecte pas les institutions
quand bien même ils soient pas refaire
et à améliorer apprécier les
institutions elles mêmes pour l'attaqué
quand on attaque les institutions font
attaquer démocratie en deux mots c'est
impuissance et défiance et puis si je
développais la défiance et le sentiment
que les institutions et ceux qui les
représentent ne servent pas les intérêts
généraux le sentiment qu'ils sont soumis
à des pressions qui sont pas des
pressions d'intérêt général une défiance
à l'endroit de la science une défiance à
l'endroit de la presse une défiance au
fond à l'endroit de tout ce qui est
installé comme système pouvoirs et
contre-pouvoirs et l'impuissance et le
sentiment que nous ne faisons pas sur le
devenir du monde et qu'au fond que ce
sont des forces politiques qui pèsent
sur l'avenir du monde des choses qui
sont extérieurs à la décision publique
ou à la décision politique la crise
démocratique elle est oui aussi
importante que la crise sanitaire
économique et social
au fond elle elle peut venir empêcher le
fait de pouvoir résoudre les crises
économiques sociales et sanitaires
on a besoin quand même d'avoir une
démocratie qui fonctionne bien pour
pouvoir résoudre les crises qui sont
devant nous crédibiliser l'action
publique
et puis dieu la crédibiliser par le fait
d'être en capacité de résoudre les
questions du real la question des
français globalement de tous les
citoyens du monde c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera à résoudre ces problèmes la
modernisation il passe sans doute par le
fait de mieux associer y compris dans le
cadre des processus de représentation
les citoyens à la prise de décision
parce qu'on a décisions qui sont
complexes qui nécessitent un éclairage
souvent multiples l'éclairage ceux qui
décident si l'éclairage de ceux pour qui
on décide pour que les choses se fassent
de la manière la plus transparente
possible
la troisième chose c'est de faire en
sorte qu'on soit à la fois sur le long
terme
est ce que ce sont des stratégies de
long terme et qui ne produisent pas leur
effet immédiatement et donc d'être en
capacité d'expliquer le chemin qui amène
à une décision politique et mon résultat
d'une décision politique et en même
temps d'être en capacité de gérer le
court terme
et puis le dernier sujet peut-être dans
cette crise démocratique c'est de ne pas
se soumettre non plus à le à la
commanderie à la domination des réseaux
sociaux et de l'immédiateté
il faut que chaque français puisse
reconnaître une partie de ce qu'elles
opinions et compris la sienne à
l'assemblée nationale or dans le système
actuel ça n'est pas favorable et la
proportionnelle est une façon de le
faire le deuxième avantage aux exams
intérêts de la proportionnelle s'il est
bien exercer c'est que ça ça conduit à
des coalitions au fond n'est pas
simplement dans la logique binaire de
majorité opposition on oblige des gens à
se positionner dans ce qui est un projet
de gouvernement il vous faut un projet
de mandature
on est quasiment le seul pays à ne pas
travailler avec de la proportionnelle en
europe
je pense qu'on a besoin d'un système qui
permette des coalitions parce que là
aussi c'est une manière d'apaiser le
débat quand bien même pour créer la
coalition puisse y avoir de la
contractualité ou du dialogue et du
débat
cette représentativité la question de la
représentativité elle est réglée par la
proportionnelle il ya toutes les autres
formes de représentativité la
représentativité c est ce que mon
opinion et reconnu puis après c'est est
ce que moi je me reconnais dans ce qui
me représente
est ce que les citoyens se reconnaissent
au travers de leurs élus quelle que soit
leur étiquette quelques longs comme ceux
qui viennent porter leur voix ça rejoint
la question de la participation
citoyenne c'est comment on fait en sorte
que les parlementaires ressemblent à
ceux qui les représentent
ce qu'il représente pardon et comment
ils se font l'écho et donc ça c'est le
travail plutôt parlementaire c'est
comment faire en sorte que le parlement
en monte en puissance en terme de
pouvoir puisse être la chambre des cours
au fond des citoyens